[Music]
ben stiller is getting candid about his
cancer battle we all have to deal with
the things life throws at us so you got
to have a sense of humor about it if you
can share that I think that is a huge
thing the 50 year old actor was
diagnosed with prostate cancer back in
2014 but didn't make the news public
until earlier this year here he is on
the today show Tuesday morning how are
you doing I'm doing great yeah I am yeah
I mean I was really fortunate you know
that my course of treatment was
basically you know an operation and and
that was it so your status today in
terms of cancer is is cancer-free as of
today you know and anybody who's had
cancer you know you just have to keep on
checking on it but I'm really fortunate
Ben had his prostate removed / his
doctor's recommendation an apparently
controversial choice you know but when
you're confronted with the question of
hey you want to live or do you want to
make sure that your sex life is the best
it could be I you know I opted for
wanting to you know get rid of the
cancer and then see what happens and
luckily I'm everything's cool
you